daily wire has this report as Canada
prepares to loosen laws related to
medical assistance in dying
prayers published by the United Church
of Canada designed to help sick and
disabled people follow through with the
lethal procedure I'll draw our drawing
criticism and shock so this is
a church quote unquote that has come up
with prayers encouraging people to kill
themselves all right
although euthanasia has been available
to many Canadians for the past six years
the nation's Parliament considered
amendments to the criminal code last
year that would expand the availability
of the practice among other changes a
citizen possessing only a mental illness
can now request euthanasia starting next
spring whereas the practice was
originally limited to individuals with
serious physical illnesses or
disabilities and we've been talking
about this uh on on this show that in
Canada
you know uh euthanasia is threatening to
become it already is a one of the
leading causes of of death in some
provinces in Canada
um
as they are taking this the the what
they call the maid law the maid act
medical assistance and dying
and they are progressively expanding it
to include more and more types of people
so long gone are the days when
euthanasia when the euthanasia
conversation revolved only around people
who are already on their deathbed who
are terminally ill who are going to die
anyway within the next few weeks it's
long gone are the days when that's when
that is what the euthanasia
conversations about
and even then even when it was just
focused on on that population of people
I opposed it
and this is one of the reasons why I
posted
because everything is a slippery slope
on the left this of course is is no
exception
if we are saying
that
suicide
you know that killing someone can be a
valid medical treatment if that's what
we're saying
then it's only a matter of time before
that is applied far beyond terminally
ill people
the whole logic between behind
euthanasia was terminally ill is that
they're they're suffering they don't
want to live anymore there's there's no
point in living when when they're
suffering so much and so the best way to
treat that suffering is just to kill
them
well it's not that far of a jump at all
in fact it's not even a jump it's just a
step
to see how well that if that if that's
the true for terminally ill people then
yeah why not someone who's depressed
why not someone who's struggling with
mental illness
they're suffering too as far as they can
see it there's no end of the suffering
life is suffering
and so I will treat this is how we will
treat the suffering
the religion of leftism is anti-religion
which means there isn't anyone to turn
to when things don't go their way
there's no Transcendent being pointing
you toward truth and Beauty there are no
Customs or Traditions to keep you on a
righteous path and there's certainly no
app like hallo to help leftists reclaim
their peace hello is an audio guided
prayer and meditation app it's the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S hello it's like calm or headspace
but without the woke nonsense because
it's rooted in Christian faith with
thousands of meditations and prayers I
use hollow to find peace after a long
day of being yelled at by blue haired
zazam weirdos they have over 5 000 audio
guided prayers meditations and Christian
music as well you can pray alongside Jim
Caviezel Bishop bear and father Mike
Schmitz Markle Wahlberg and many more
hello helps me make prayer a priority
and they can do the same for you so get
an exclusive three-month trial at
hallow.com Matt Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh reclaim your piece in this
crazy world download hello today
anyway back to the um United Church of
Canada
it's called The Prayer in the midst of
fear which is co-authored by United
Church of Canada Minister and the former
co-president of dying with dignity and
advocacy Group which supported the
legalization of assisted suicide in
Canada it can be described as an
exercise in radical autonomy the
supplication centers upon asking God
that family members would accept their
loved one's decision to kill themselves
with the aid of medical professionals
making no mention of eternal life
secured through the death and
Resurrection Jesus Christ the prayer
attempts to embrace an uncertainty about
death
so here's part of the prayer
again this this was uh devised by the
United Church of Canada
says I am afraid I feel fear penetrating
my mind and my heart I feel fear in my
gut I am afraid to die I do not know
what lies beyond the barrier of death
I am afraid to release myself to the
great unknown
I am heartbroken and afraid to leave my
family I am still needed
I have let go of Hope and healing I hold
on to hope for the next life
I'm afraid that my family and loved ones
children and grandchildren will be
troubled when I tell them I plan to die
using Medical Aid and dying
but in the midst of my fear I have hope
that my family and loved ones children
and grandchildren will understand the
choice to end my suffering I hope
they'll be proud of my decision and will
understand that made is consistent with
the love and compassion of Jesus
and then it goes I can't even keep
reading this I mean this is this is
obviously not a Christian prayer this is
a demonic incantation
this is a a you know this is this is a a
mockery of of Christianity this is
Christianity turned on its head
because Christianity is a is a is is
hope it is a religion a faith
of Hope and this is
the abandonment of Hope
says I hope that my family will be proud
that they'll be proud that I killed
myself
because I don't want to suffer anymore
this is what happens when you when you
put we talk about the slippery slope
when you put doctors in charge of
killing people when you say to doctors
that this is now a valid treatment that
could be available to some people
this is this is where it leads
and uh it was entirely predictable
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or have listened to the full show
head to dailywire.com And subscribe
today you can also listen to my podcast
on Spotify Apple podcast or wherever you
get your podcasts